le souligner comment peut-on
reconstituer une sixième république qui
ne soit pas un à l'oubli parlementaire
ça se passe en direct puisque on est en
direct il y a quand même la liberté je
vous remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose
une convention admise par tous
s'il arrive quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash nous vous parlerons de
tout sans langue de bois
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous nous sommes ensemble
comme chaque jour du lundi au jeudi
jusqu'à 21h30 pour décrypter les grands
titres de l'actualité de la journée au
sommaire de ce mercredi 8 septembre la
france qui évoque des actes qui ne
suivent pas les paroles au lendemain de
l'annoncé de l'équipe dirigeante afghane
qui ne comprend aucune femme
contrairement aux promesses d'ouverture
du régime l'américain intel blinken
estime lui que les talibans devront
gagner leur légitimité auprès de la
communauté internationale
un gouvernement taliban qui sonne en
tout cas comme un pied-de-nez à
l'administration de washington et la
communauté internationale
décryptage dans quelques instants
au sommaire de cette émission également
les grands chantiers de la dernière
ligne droite du quinquennat macron à j
moins 200 avant le premier tour de la
présidentielle jean castex a dévoilé le
programme des réformes exit celle des
retraites les conditions n'étant pas
réunies l'associé l'assurance chômage
elle entrera bien en vigueur le 1er
octobre 200 jours pour agir jusqu'au
bout a martelé un premier ministre alors
que le président devra porter son bilan
quoi qu'il en coûte ce sera l'objet de
l'édito d'alexis paulin
et puis à 21h notre nouveau rendez-vous
qu'en pensent les français consacré ce
soir à l'ouverture du procès historique
des attaques du 13 novembre 2015 à paris
notre reporter cassia technique et elle
est à la rencontre de parents meurtris
par l'assassinât de leurs deux filles
sur l'une des terrasses du 11e
arrondissement
si les neuf mois d'audience devait faire
la lumière sur de nombreuses zones
d'ombré l'enjeu politique est bien
elle alors quelles sont les mesures
prises par le pays pour faire face au
terrorisme qu'en est il du suivi des
fichiers est désormais le pays est il en
mesure aujourd'hui de prévenir de
nouvelles attaques nous en débattrons
sur ce plateau
[Musique]
les actes qui ne suivent pas les paroles
déplore jean yves le drian déception
également plus voilé celle ci du côté
américain qui tente tout de même de
garder la face l'inquiétude est en tous
les cas partagé par de nombreux afghans
qui bravent la nouvelle autorité
plusieurs manifestations ont quitté les
bancs ont été réprimées ces derniers
jours ont fait le point avec amaya son
blé et maxime a bola
de nouvelles manifestations anti
talibans malgré les réprimandes ce
mercredi des afghanes continuent de
protester contre le gouvernement par
intérim dans la continuité de ce mardi
alors que ces rassemblements ont été
interdits
aux membres à zapatera mais ces
manifestations sont illégales tant que
les bureaux du gouvernement n'ont pas
ouvert et que les lois ne soient pas
proclamés
ce mardi les manifestations causé de
décès par balle à et rate une première
depuis la prise de pouvoir des insurgés
des coups de feu ont également été tirés
dans la capitale
dans le même temps les talibans ont
annoncé leur nouveau gouvernement emmené
par mohammad hassan al quds figures
proches du fondateur du mouvement
islamiste
autour de lui les ministres nommés sont
exclusivement des hommes mais certains
postes encore libres pourraient être
attribués à d'autres groupes fable about
modem qui
combine toutes les agences
gouvernementales n'ont pas encore été
annoncés certains postes ministériels
directeurs et adjoints restent vacants
et des efforts sont en cours pour les
pourvoir des efforts sont également
faits pour que des personnes de
différentes régions et de tout le pays
joue un rôle dans ce processus
de nombreuses figures emblématiques ont
été nommés à la tête de ce gouvernement
par intérim à 12 ghani baradar
cofondateur du mouvement devient le
numéro deux du nouvel exécutif
considérée comme terroriste est
activement recherché par le fbi à
sirajuddin haqqani leader du réseau
éponyme est nommé ministre de
l'intérieur lors d'une de ses rares
prises de parole le chef suprême des
talibans invité le nouveau gouvernement
à appliquer la charia dans tout le pays
il affirme que le nouveau gouvernement
souhaite installer je cite une paix et
une prospérité et un développement
durable en afghanistan mais si les
talibans ont annoncé faire respecter le
droit des femmes et des filles sur le
sol afghan la nomination d'un
gouvernement exclusivement masculin fait
douter de leur engagement récent à ce
sujet selon la responsable d'onu femmes
le département d'état américain a quant
à lui fait part de ses préoccupations
et les états unis qui tentent de garder
la face et reste prudent quant à la
réaction sur le nouveau gouvernement il
énonce attendent de pouvoir juger les
nouveaux hommes forts sur leurs actes on
retrouve notre correspondant à new york
que thomas bonnet bonsoir marçais depuis
l'allemagne que la diplomatie américaine
organise sa réponse à la formation du
gouvernement par les talibans
oui parce que washington veut apporter
une réponse commune c'est à ce nouveau
gouvernement formé par les talibans
c'est la raison pour laquelle une
réunion en visioconférence s'est tenue
aujourd'hui au tour d' anthony blinken
et de son homologue allemand heiko maas
22 pays y ont participé dont des
représentants également de l'otan et de
l'union européenne
le chef de la diplomatie allemande qui
s'est d'ailleurs dit favorable à une
approche commune de la part des alliés
occidentaux à l'égard des talibans reste
que les premiers noms de cette nouvelle
équipe gouvernementale formée par les
talibans risquent de poser problème pour
les états unis vous l'avais dit il ya
quasi exclusivement des talibans ou des
personnes qui sont proches du mouvement
pas volonté en apparence en tout cas
d'inclusivité comme cela avait pourtant
été explicitement demandée par
washington voici donc ce qu'en dit
anthony blinken c'était est aujourd'hui
depuis l'allemagne
nouveau gouvernement intérimaire nous
évaluons annonce mais bien qu'ils
prétendent qu'un nouveau gouvernement
serait inclusif la liste de noms
annoncés se compose exclusivement
d'individus membres des talibans
ou de leurs proches collaborateurs et
aucune femme nous sommes également
préoccupés par les affiliations et les
antécédents de certaines de ces
personnes nous comprenons sur les
talibans ont présenté cela comme un
cabinet intérimaire nous les jugerons
ainsi que sur ses actions la communauté
internationale a clairement indiqué
qu'elle s'attendait à ce que les afghans
mérite un gouvernement plus
[Musique]
alors la maison blanche indique que rien
ne presse quant à une reconnaissance
officielle de la part des autorités
américaines de se gouverner de ce
nouveau gouvernement par intérim
anthony blinken qui a aussi affirmé
aujourd'hui que les talibans devront
gagner leur légitimité auprès de la
communauté internationale avec à des
actes et la priorité pour washington à
l'heure actuelle c'est de mener à bien
les évacuations des civils encore sur
place en afghanistan s'est d'ailleurs
pas un hasard si anthony blinken s'est
rendu à la fois au qatar et en allemagne
parce que ce sont deux pays de transit
qui ont été très importants ces derniers
jours pour l'évacuation des civils
d'afghanistan cette question de
l'évacuation c'est un sujet majeur car
c'est le sujet qui cristallise la
plupart des critiques contre le
gouvernement de joe biden le département
d'état américain a affirmé à de
nombreuses reprises qu'il n'avait plus
suffisamment de personnel sur place pour
procéder aux contrôles nécessaires qui
permettent qui permettrait aux avions de
décoller et d'afghanistan blinken a
aussi indiqué aujourd'hui que les
talibans avaient eux-mêmes bloquer le
départ d'un avion ou d'un avion faute de
documents de voyage nécessaires pour les
personnes qui souhaitaient donc quitter
l'afghanistan tout cela fait qu'il ya un
certain nombre de critiques qui sont
exprimées par des élus notamment d
républicain qui reproche à joe biden une
forme d'inaction une forme même de
passivité sur la question de
l'évacuation des civils et notamment des
civils américains encore en afghanistan
merci thomas bonnin en direct de new
york de la prudence embarrassé donc pour
les américains reprochent plus clair de
la part des européens une voix
dissonante on va le voir de la part de
pékin qui affiche son pragmatisme
que se cache-t-il derrière ces
différentes réactions internationales
après les annonces du gouvernement
taliban hier soir c'est l'objet de notre
décryptage
[Musique]
est avec nous pour en parler ce soir
olivier caunes ancien officier en
afghanistan ex-conseiller politique à
kaboul de l'ambassadeur européen bonsoir
olivier creuse merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous à vos côtés régis le sommier
grand reporter rt france bonsoir régis
le sommier donc vous avez donc passé 80
olivier kohn en afghanistan vous avez
servi comme militaire puis comme
diplomate vous connaissez donc très bien
effectivement le terrain mais aussi
l'aspect plus diplomatique quand on voit
ce message un petit peu voilà ce libye
l'un des américains qui n'osent pas trop
reprocher clairement se dit quoi on n'a
pas le choix on essaye de garder la
farce
savait qu'elle qu'est ce qu'est ce que
peut faire les américains concrètement
je veux dire là il faut il faut il
faut comprendre la situation la guerre
est perdue il faut l'admettre c'est un
fait donc les aveugles et les américains
ont quitté le territoire afghan s'est
terminée la guerre est finie donc il ne
reste plus grand chose à faire sinon
deux sinon d'évacuer les tous les
afghans qui la coalition a travaillé ce
que fait la france par ailleurs
également quoi donc le constat
effectivement est difficile mais que
faire d'autre effectivement que faire
d'autre régis le sommier les américains
qui se disent préoccupés
le mot est un petit peu bizarrement
choisi mais attendent de voir de voir
quoi c'est un échec clairement alors
cette nomination de ce gouvernement dit
intérimaire donc on verra comment les
choses vont se sache il y aura peut-être
d'autres personnalités et d'autres noms
qui vont poindre c'est quand même
globalement une gifle à la flamme à la
face de la mairie qu'il faut le
reconnaître dans ce gouvernement
figurent ping comme chef du gouvernement
quelqu'un qui a eu dont le fils est mort
dans un attentat suicide comme kamikazes
vous avez donc sirajuddin haqqani qui
étaient directement sur une liste liste
américaine y avait une rivière et
comment à une demande de rançon de 10
millions de dollars sur sa tête parce
qu'il a été comment identifier comme
responsable d'un des pires attentats qui
a été commis à kaboul contre
l'intercontinental n'y avait eu un peu
plus de 100 morts une véritable attaque
de cet hôtel international donc voilà
dans le gouvernement figurent des aussi
quatre anciens de guantanamo qui ont du
sang sur les mains clairement le message
que l'état ybrant voulu faire passer
c'est d'abord un message en interne
c'est avoir un message de dire quand on
dit gouvernement inclusif il est
inclusif à la talibane c'est à dire ça
inclut toutes les parties du mouvement
les durs donc haqqani et puis les un peu
plus modérées baradar encore que baradar
comme j'ai dis déjà ici ne doit son nom
ont directement au mollah omar ça veut
dire frères le mollah omar l'appeler
frères dont vous avez le mollah ah koon
et le mollah baradar
les deux exécutifs du du gouvernement
qui sont directement liés au mollah omar
donc à l'équipe précédente à coosa
d'ascq et le guide spirituel également
lui était en charge de la cheville de
l'administration de la charia dans la
précédente équipe on se souvient de la
duty 2 comment et la sauvagerie dont
avait fait preuve les talibans à
l'époque pour l'application de la loi
coranique donc on peut se dire que
clairement on a non seulement une équipe
qui est très dur mais on a aussi des
gens qui ont été en contact avec ben
laden à l'époque qui ont probablement
assister à ce qu'on a appelé la bahia
c'est à dire là comment le serment
d'allégeance
al qaida aux talibans au mollah omar en
personne pour la voix les avoir
accueillis en afghanistan bon les liens
on sait entre les talibans et al qaïda
n'ont jamais été complètement comment
ce serment s'être bahia elle a été
renouvelée au fil des ans donc on se
rend compte que là dessus il ya des
choses qui sont quand même très
inquiétante même d'un point de vue
américain même si on peut dire que les
américains attendent sans doute que les
talibans montrent peut-être une forme
d'ouverture grâce certainement pas de
femmes à mon sens mais peut-être
quelques figures de l'opposition qui
viendraient un peu a
envoyé un message à la communauté
internationale parce que les talibans
vont avoir besoin d'argent ils vont
avoir besoin de soutien économique les
chinois on l'a dit sont déjà dans la
place mais ça ne suffira peut-être pas
en tout cas anthony avait une canne un
pur pour finir sur sur l'analyse de ces
réactions parce qu'elles sont
effectivement intéressante et elle cache
beaucoup de d'arrière pensées bien
évidemment tony blinken arrivée en
allemagne avec l'espoir d'avoir une
réponse un petit peu coordonnée sur la
nomination de ce gouvernement c'est raté
la france est clairement plus clairement
les exigences de la communauté
internationale ne sont pas remplies
l'union européenne 1 déplore de son côté
ce gouvernement on l'a dit ni inclusif
ni représentatif
comment vous l'analysez olivet crown
seule différence de son de cloche et ne
pas avoir fédéré finalement pour anthony
blinken
ben disons que le son de cloche il est
pas si différent ça en réalité parce que
la déclaration de l'union européenne l'a
dernièrement ça a été une sorte de
déception un peu officiel de
devant ce gouvernement taleb quoi que
régis vient d'écrire je pense qu'il faut
se faire strictement aucune illusion
lire les talibans nouvelle version vingt
ans après non non pas changé sur le fond
la substance est la même ils se sont
modernisées utilisons des comptes
twitter etc mais le fond c'est le même
le programme c'est le même maintenant ça
faisait vingt ans qu'ils étaient ceux
qui combattaient pour reprendre le
pouvoir parce qu'à l'époque entre 96 et
2001 il avait il était à kaboul mais il
contrôlait pas tout l'afghanistan on
contrôlait pas tout l'afghanistan il eu
mon il leur manquait le dernier tiers la
ligne de front
coin ça va passer par le panchir qui
vient de tomber
donc je veux dire il ya sur le fond y'a
rien qui a changé ça veut dire quoi tout
ça pour ça des milliards après
désarmement qui se retrouve maintenant
aux mains des talibans c'est peut-être
ça le grand changement ça veut dire le
point zéro pour vous réellement tout ça
pour ça évidemment c'est une question
qu'on se pose tous sauf un quiconque a
servi ou est passé en afghanistan
il a man se pose forcément cette
question là tout ça pour ça mais on peut
jamais le savoir on peut jamais savoir
comment la faire se termine donc si vous
voulez il ya un constat c'est que
la partie est perdue ça ne veut pas dire
que sur les vingt ans d'engagement de la
coalition là bas il ne restera rien il
ya eu des infrastructures qu'on était
quand même bâti construit il ya eu des
toute une génération qui a été scolarisé
malgré tout il en restera quelque chose
même si l'élite est en train de partir
de quitter le pays en fin c'est le
ccsp talibans s'en plaignait tout
absolument mais enfin bon il restera
toujours quelque chose
voilà bon même si même si l'affairé
perdue maintenant la galère question
effectivement c'est comment
l'afghanistan d'état hleb avec un
gouvernement taliban qui est taliban au
pouvoir comment vont-ils s'en sortir
parce que le pays était sous perfusion
économique pendant 20 ans par la
communauté internationale
donc tout ça c'est fini je veux dire les
robinets sont finis tout les les flux
sans couper il reste certainement des
acteurs régionaux régissent le site et
la chine qui a probablement pour enfin
seraient potentiellement on va dire
pourrait potentiellement être un acteur
qui prendrait entre guillemets la relève
et encore et encore justement c'est
intéressant parce que la réaction de la
chine et pour le coup très dissonante
elle clairement je vous propose de
l'écouter avant d'en parler
la chine attache une grande importance à
l'annonce par les talibans de la mise en
place d'un gouvernement provisoire et de
certains arrangements importants
concernant le personnel
cela mis fin à plus de trois semaines
d'anarchie en afghanistan et constitue
une étape nécessaire pour rétablir
l'ordre et reconstruire le pays
nous avons également noté que les
taliban ont déclaré que le gouvernement
intérimaire devait rétablir l'ordre
social et économique le plus rapidement
possible
on voit dans cette réaction le
pragmatisme chinois et et pour le coup
l'arrière pensée tout à fait les chinois
ne raisonne pas du tout comme nous il
faut prendre ça en considération il ne
voit pas du tout la thalie le
l'afghanistan comme un pays ou une
entité avec un gouvernement il le voit
comme une voie de passage comme une voie
de passage qui fait partie de leur
fameux projet de route de la soie il ya
même plusieurs mais en tout cas ils
pensent l'aghanistan exactement comme
les grands conquérants l'on pense et
c'est à dire comme un chemin comme un
chemin qu'on veut contrôler comme une
zone qu'on veut contrôler mais pas
tellement comme un pays en réalité donc
ce qui leur apporte aujourd'hui c'est là
ce qui est le propos de ce ministre
chinois est important c'est l'idée de la
stabilité et de l'ordre est ce que les
chinois on le rappelle on dans le dans
leurs dents dans l'ouest du pays une
certaine population musulmane assez
importantes dont ont émergé d'ailleurs
des mouvements jihadistes
parmi les ouïghours qui a dix qui se
sont d'ailleurs répandue à travers le
monde on en trouve jusqu'en syrie et est
donc ils n'ont pas du tout envie que
l'arrivée au pouvoir d'un émirat
islamique
avec des taliban à leurs frontières je
rappelle qui est 90 km de frontière
entre la chine et l'afghanistan se
concrétise par un museau d'instabilité
chez eux c'est aussi le cas des russes
pour toutes leur sphère d'influencé avec
les anciennes républiques soviétiques
musulmane donc l'ouzbékistan le
tadjikistan le kirghizstan qui sont
juste au nord personne n'a envie de voir
déborder une forme d'instabilité ou de
voir un effet talibans dans son pays
donc le retour à l'ordre est primordial
pour les chinois et puis évidemment
après cela s'accompagnera t-il d'une
aide économique ça ça reste à voir vous
l'avez assez justement dit parce qu'à
chaque fois comme pour la reconstruction
de la syrie et chinois arrivent et
disent on est là on est là on est là et
puis ça attend ça à temps et il ya
beaucoup de conditions avant que les
chinois régis mais cela dit sur les
plats question talibane il avait pris
langue avec le mouvement bien avant son
arrivée au pouvoir
à kaboul le 15 août dernier et il y
avait déjà eu le ministre des affaires
étrangères chinois qui s'était affichée
donc là il ya une sorte de pragmatisme
absolue giret et - d'atermoiements sur
qui est dans le gouvernement ce qui est
ce que semble au contraire craindre la
plupart des pays occidentaux alors quel
avenir maintenant vous avez commencé à
nous en parlait tout à l'heure pour vous
pas beaucoup de changement c'est la vie
d'une femme elle s'appelle faouzia
confie elle était figurez-vous ancien
député donc au parlement avant puisque
vous ne m'aviez dit l'autre jour il y
avait bien des femmes au parlement
allait pas effectivement et je vous
propose justement d'écouter son analyse
par rapport à leur premier règne ils
veulent faire croire qu'ils ont changé
mais ce changement n'existe qu'au niveau
de leurs dirigeants politiques eux ont
voyagé à l'étranger en russie en turquie
en chine au kazakhstan et au qatar en
réalité les combattants et les
commandants talibans qui ne connaissent
que la guerre et les armes ne peuvent
accepter les changements de la société
afghane
olivier pon c est intéressant ce qu'elle
soulève cette ancienne députée afghane
clairement il ya une différence notable
entre le combattant du terrain vous avez
certainement croiser souvent et le
dirigeant qui s'est pas émancipés mais
en tout cas qui a qui a voyagé qui a les
codes
des occidentaux
les codes des occidentaux c'est un bien
grand mot membres et peut-être un type
avait en tout cas elle mais
effectivement on oria de l'élite
talibane si on peut parler si on
pourrait les appeler tristement comme ça
mais effectivement ce sont des gens qui
pour partie était réfugié enfin se
cacher au pakistan voilà il ya une
différence fondamentale effectivement
entre les vieux cadres enfin qui eux
mêmes ont fait du terrain parce que la
plupart bleus mais les régissent tout à
l'heure c'est ce sont des gars qui ont
mouillé le maillot quand combattu à une
autre époque à 20 ans ont maintenant ils
sont aux commandes donc une partie
effectivement se cacher au pakistan
parce qu'ils étaient ciblés par par la
coalition par les américains
ensuite il y en a quelques-uns d'entre
eux qui ont été engagées dans des
moments dans l'est dans les discussions
diplomatiques à doha donc c'est
effectivement il y en a un petit groupe
parmi eux qui en comme venait de le
citer la députée convoyage et qui sont
allés un mot sur nous à doha et c'est
maintenant le effectivement il ya une
différence entre eux et le conte et le
combattant taleb qui lui est rustique
qui est
capable en ouverture d'esprit ça reste
quand même voilà un combattant de base
qui a fait vingt ans de guerre 21 je
veux dire lui débarque à kaboul ou
ailleurs d'ailleurs faut pas s'attendre
à une grande tolérance de leur part ça
c'est certain effectivement
les députés eux mêmes c'est avec la
constitution afghane prévoyait
un quota de 20 % de députées qui doit
être des femmes comment donc il y avait
un important de du parlement afghan qui
était composé de deux femmes je pense
que ce temps là est révolu bel et bien
terminé ce qui est intéressant pour
poursuivre c'est que même à certains
moments des négociations de douar qui
ont duré plusieurs années il ya eu
parfois des dissensions entre
le groupe présent à doha et les
combattants sur le terrain qui disait
pendant vous bavarder nous on fait la
guerre on pratique une forme d'austérité
vous vivez luxueusement dans des
hôtels il ya eu dans le mouvement
taliban des critiques justement sur ces
négociations de la part du terrain et de
la part des militaires sur le terrain
des durs du mouvement notamment
vis-à-vis de ses négociations avec les
américains je rajouterais une précision
là dessus à l'époque des généraux que
vous avez connu une régis qui ont été
nos grands chefs de la coalition où je
rappelle qu'on était quand même 150
mille hommes sur le terrain au plus fort
de la guerre des généraux comme crystal
ou petraeus qui sont quand même des
ventes figurent militaire une des
semaines de leur stratégie à l'époque
c'était de deux cibles et de décapiter
soul et les commandants terrain de
terrain je précise bien de terrain parce
que les grands chefs se cachait au
pakistan il est très difficile de les
signer donc ça a été une stratégie
c'était d'éliminer soul est l'équivalent
des lieutenants et des capitaines entre
guillemets pour faire une comparaison
avec une armée moderne et donc ça a été
ces gars-là énormément ramassé sur le
terrain voilà donc ils n'ont pas vécu la
même guerre que le chef qui est dès que
le chef taleb à quetta peshawar il y
avait deux choix par ailleurs à l'époque
j'avais des dissensions au sein du
mouvement taliban mais voilà c'est ce et
voilà c'est pas tout à fait la même
guerre maintenant la force et elle est
pareil jouer le lay a pas de
fondamentalement de différence entre le
grand chef qui est allé à moscou à doha
etc et puis le taleb qui lui a fait
monter au carton sur le terrain quoi
c'est le programme n'est pas rien juste
pour conclure ce décryptage look avait
justement on lisait passé quatre ans en
tant qu'officier sur le terrain
peut-être un sentiment plus personnel
aujourd'hui c'est quoi c'est un
sentiment d'échec en afghanistan c'est
qu'est ce que vous ressentez
c'est un sentiment très difficile c'est
le lourd sentiment difficile et
douloureux séquence est effectivement en
reste sur un échec pour passer c'est un
constat il faut s'y faire c'est
douloureux mais c'est une réalité donc
on se pose la question tout ça pour ça
mais on pouvait pas le savoir au début
et je pense - personnellement mais son
avis personnel que la cause était juste
quoi la cause était juste on est parti
là-bas après voilà on est ça a été un
engrenage puis ça s'est terminé
malheureusement comme ça mais voilà on
revient on rembobine pas là le film
c'est voilà la partie de jouer ce qu'il
faut savoir c'est que
le programme talibans s'étaient de
conquérir il y avait un programme il y
avait un réel programme politique
prendre le pouvoir à kaboul prendre
contrôler l'afghanistan et ils avaient
une stratégie militaire je pense que
nous avons sous-estimé
il y avait une réelle stratégie
militaire je pourrais citer des exemples
voilà qui sont peut-être un peu méconnu
mais mais voilà ils avaient ils étaient
déterminés ils ont fait vingt ans de
guerre et ils y sont arrivés voilà et si
vous voulez en face le constat on peut
peut-être le plus douloureux de voir
l'armée afghanes auxquelles nous avons
participé à
constituer à former enfin ça a coûté des
milliards ça coûte et enfin en
ressources est colossal qui ces
courageux et courageusement battu je
tiens à le préciser
alors ça s'est effondré sur la fin parce
que si vous voulez quand vous avez le
chef qui se barre comprenez une armée ne
continue pas de se battre sur le terrain
quand le chef se barre bon c'est fini et
le président afghan ashraf ghani a été
le premier à monter dans l'avion on va
[ __ ] le camp
c'est profond regret ce soir que mon
propre jeu rapide se soit terminée sur
une tragédie similaire
merci à tous les deux en tout cas merci
d'avoir été là merci régie se souvenir
vous retrouvera évidemment vous pouvez
nous dire encore beaucoup de choses je
vouvoyais réagir merci à vous en tout
cas tous les deux
en france à présent d'un et séminaire de
rentrée pour le gouvernement ce mercredi
après un court conseil des ministres les
membres du gouvernement étaient conviés
par emmanuel macron une réunion objectif
préparer les 200 derniers jours de son
mandat maxime hébert
assurance chômage retraites justice
délinquance et santé jean castex
détaillait ce mercredi les grands axes
des 200 derniers jours avant la
présidentielle d'avril prochain
inquiétudes récurrentes du mandat d'
emmanuel macron la réforme des retraites
une nécessité absolue pour le premier
ministre qui malgré la grogne sociale
envisage donc toujours sa mise en oeuvre
la crise sanitaire a interrompu le
processus de réformes
est comme gelée redit aux partenaires
sociaux lorsque je les ai reçus la
semaine dernière ce processus dure est
modifié compte tenu des conditions
nouvelles ne pourra reprendre que
lorsque la pandémie sera sous contrôle
et que la reprise économique sera
suffisamment solide c'est une question
de bon sens j'allais dire c'est un
préalable à la réussite de cette réforme
très importante une réforme en chassera
telle une autre si celle des retraites
s'écrit en pointillés celle de
l'assurance chômage semble acté jean
castex a annoncé sa mise en application
progressive entre le 1er octobre et le
1er décembre prochain
globalement bien accueilli par les
représentants du patronat le projet de
loi est toujours dans le viseur des
syndics un appel à une mobilisation
générale a été lancé pour le 5 octobre
prochain même si le locataire de l'hôtel
matignon s'est voulu rassurant j'ai
également face aux craintes exprimées
dans les syndicats et que vous
connaissez indiqué que nous mettrions en
place un dispositif de suivi et
d'évaluation
de la mise en oeuvre de cette réforme
pour en mesurer les effets enfin jean
castex a évoqué les besoins de
moderniser la justice et les services de
santé alors qu emmanuel macron lancera
le mois prochain les états généraux de
la justice avant le lancement de la
phase ii du ségur de la santé dans les
prochaines semaines les chantiers
s'annonce encore nombreux jusqu'à
l'élection présidentielle de 2000 22
alors que retenir de ces annonces du
premier ministre avec en filigrane bien
sûr l'objectif sans doute d'une campagne
présidentielle pour emmanuel macron pour
en parler nous sommes avec alexis
poulain éditorialise bonsoir alexis le
chef d'état qui veut avancer sur son
projet de réforme des retraites avant la
fin de ce quinquennat mais mais
visiblement les conditions ne seront pas
réunir
et oui on voit bien que emmanuel macron
voudrait aller encore plus vite pour
cette réforme des retraites continue et
c'est bien sur la feuille de route de la
commission européenne pour les milliards
débloqués milliards de dettes adepte
qu'ovide il doit faire des réformes
structurelles entendez la réforme de la
lotus de l'allocation chômage et la
réforme des retraites dont emmanuel
macron veut y aller veut faire aussi
preuve de
réformisme puisqu'il a été élu pour ça
et qu'il a été empêché par cette crise
sanitaire avant l'élection évidemment de
2022 ce serait dommage de ne pas montrer
qu'il est ce président réformateur qu'il
prétend vouloir être donc il veut
remettre ça sur la table mais évidemment
tous les partenaires sociaux étaient
contre avant la crise du coc vide
edouard philippe était alors premier
ministre à la place de jean castex il
voulait passer par la force le 49 3 eme
le maquereau envisage également les
décrets or on le voit aujourd'hui les
syndicats sont contre le patronat
commence un peu à voir que le temps
presse alors pourquoi pas mais une
inquiétude demeure quand j'entends
monsieur castex dire qu'il y aura un
comité d'évaluation pour voir l'impact
de ces réformes delà de la retraite
regardez tous les comités d'évaluation
qui ont existé par le passé où sont
passés par exemple le comité citoyen qui
étaient là pour donner son avis sur la
vaccination envolée évaporés dans l'air
donc on peut penser que le comité
d'évaluation pour les retraites sera à
peu près du même acabit
l'idée c'est d'aller vite de continuer
la casse sociale imposée par la
politique progressiste comme il aime à
l'appeler emmanuel macron et bien sûr
demandé par la commission européenne
mais on voit bien que les conditions ne
sont pas réunies évidemment crise
sanitaire d'un côté crise économique de
l'autre on est loin d'une vraie reprise
économique on est loin encore d'avoir
endiguer complètement ce virus donc
il sait de l'attentisme évidemment c'est
de l' effet d'annonce avec le risque
encore une fois de braquer davantage une
population française déjà fracturé et
déjà fatigués de 4 ans demande à des
monnaies de macron alexis en revanche
les conditions sont bel et bien réunis
pour la réforme de l'assurance chômage
très décrié a notamment parlé et
syndicats qui est selon jean castex
absolument indispensable elle sera bien
appliquée à partir du 1er octobre
celle-ci
oui là encore on voit bien là la
radicalité idéologique de ce
gouvernement qui veut aller vite dans
ses réformes structurelles promises à
l'union européenne donc il va falloir
accélérer la précarisation de ceux qui
sont déjà dans la précarité l'idée étant
que quand on est au chômage hall l'est
par choix c'est faux on l'est par défaut
parce qu'il est difficile de trouver un
travail dans ses champs de compétence
alors il y a bien sûr le pack de
formation continue mais ça ne suffit pas
quand on regarde le nombre d'offres
d'emploi et le nombre de demandeurs le
delta excusez moi c'est pas le variant
delta mais la différence est énorme et
donc on ne voit pas comment ce chômage
de masse pourrait disparaître du jour au
lendemain parce que les allocations
chômage vont diminuer donc encore une
fois la pauvreté est un choix politique
c'est c'était celle du gouvernement
thatcher de la politique du guichet du
gouvernement également schröder en
allemagne avec les lois ars qui ont mis
en place cette difficulté pour les
chômeurs d'être indemnisés alors que
rappelons le le chômage n'est pas un
cadeau les travailleurs cotisent tout le
long de leur vie de travail pour ce
moment où ils n'ont pas de travail ce
n'est pas un dû ce n'est pas un cadeau
c'est quelque chose qui coûte aux
travailleurs et aux employeurs et là on
voit bien que la logique derrière c'est
de dire eh bien débrouillé vous après
tout la start up nation c'est l'ubs et
risation et c'est encore moins de droits
sociaux encore moins de tapis sociale or
c'est cette république sociale qui a
permis à la france de survoler la crise
de 2008 qui a impacté la grèce et
d'autres pays beaucoup plus sévèrement
qui a permis aussi à la france de sortir
ces milliards pour aider les secteurs
comme la restauration et continuer
encore aujourd'hui même si le quoi qu'il
en coûte
enfin et c'est cette force là finalement
qu'on va mettre à la poubelle tout
simplement par idéologie pour s'aligner
encore une fois sur les partenaires
européens sans réfléchir de ce qu'il
sera par la suite si une crise encore
plus grave qu'elle soit économique
systémique bancaire ou autre arrivait à
toucher l'europe et la france et malgré
cet exercice également une communication
alexis qui sont ce séminaire
gouvernemental et plus tard évidemment
cette université d'été début octobre de
la république en marche il y a tout de
même un sondage important alors on s'en
méfie parfois mais tout de même un
président juge est loin des français
dans une majorité ne souhaite pas
finalement qu'il se représente
oui c'est un sondage qui a été publiée
par libération alors je ne sais plus
quel institut qui qu'il a réalisés mais
on voit que c'est à peu près 60% de
français qui ne souhaite pas qu'ils
menaient le makrout se représente avec
une majorité écrasante de français là on
est 70 80 % qui juge emmanuel macron
loin de leur quotidien
décalé des finalement d'un coupé des
français ça c'est pas nouveau il a ce
sobriquet de président des riches on
voit qu'il est vraiment loin évidemment
du quotidien des français dans sa
pratique du pouvoir il aime plutôt
rencontrer les patrons de fonds
d'investissement comme blackrock à
versailles de temps en temps il va dans
des villes comme marseille mais là on
voit bien que les villes sont barricadés
et puis après cdd mise en scène pour on
a vu pendant trois jours pour montrer
qu'il est un président populaire mais
même cet été il n'a pas fait le
traditionnel bain de foule à brégançon à
qu'il faisait chaque année c'est vous
dire comme le divorce est complet entre
la population française et ce président
qui est en voie finalement de hollande
isation un françois hollande qui à la
fin de son mandat était également
totalement mal aimé des français ne
voulaient pas le voir se représentait
d'ailleurs il avait fait le choix de ne
pas se présenter mais emmanuel macron
est très différent il aime la
confrontation il aime la violence il
sera prêt je pense à se présenter contre
l'avis de tous sachant qu'ils peuvent
être aidés par les sondages on en parle
est incertain sondages peuvent être
biaisées ou arrondir son image alors
qu'il va proposer des réformes sociales
difficiles dur est encore plus
d'inégalités à la suite de ces réformes
donc il peut compter sur ce type de
communication c'est d'ailleurs ce que
fait la république en marche avec
richard ferrand hier arrangé pour la
rentrée parlementaire des macros nist
qui disait que emmanuel macron est le
candidat unique du 21e siècle c'est le
seul candidat de la modernité politique
on en est là c'est quasiment du mao dans
le texte donc pourquoi pas si les
maquereaux nice pense que 50 plus pour
un candidat unique le seul et l'unique
je crois que les français quand on voit
ce sondage attendent autre chose de
l'offre politique et du débat pour la
présidentielle de 2000 22 merci beaucoup
alexis poulain en direct sur arte france
sur le front du coc vide à présent le
conseil d'état ne se prononce pas sur le
passé militaire obligatoire dans
certains centres commerciaux de plus de
20 mille mètres carrés encore effective
dans plusieurs départements une décision
plus que contrariante pour le
gouvernement désormais dans l'impasse
david kelly frappe pour les détails
un réflexe qui ne sera plus obligatoire
mais pas pour tous les centres
commerciaux de l'hexagone car si la
mesure du gouvernement est allégé ce
sont 64 centres commerciaux de plus de
20 mille mètres carrés de neuf
départements qui sont encore concernées
par l'obligation de présenter le fameux
sésame dans ces départements le taux
d'incidence du coc vie demeure supérieur
à 200 pour cent mille habitants sur une
semaine soit le seuil voulue par la loi
cas particulier pour les yvelines face
au texte deux avocats ont décidé de
saisir la justice sous forme de référé
le tribunal administratif de versailles
leur a donné raison et a suspendu
l'arrêté préfectoral
les articles 1er et 2 de l'arrêté du
préfet des yvelines du 19 août 2021
fixant la liste des grands magasins et
centres commerciaux des yvelines dont
l'accès est subordonnée à la
présentation du pass sanitaires sont
suspendus tant qu'il ne prévoit pas les
conditions garantissant l'accès des
personnes ne disposant pas de passes
annie terre aux établissements
commercialisant des biens de première
nécessité
situé dans l'enceinte de ses magasins et
centres le gouvernement a immédiatement
fait appel mais le conseil d'état a
décidé de ne pas se prononcer sur ce
recours ce mercredi pour une raison qui
pose question le préfet a finalement
suspendu l'arrêté en question puisque le
taux d'incidence est passé en dessous
des 200 mardi soir timing parfait ou
simple des aveux du ministère de la
santé l'avocat en charge de la faire a
sa petite idée
cela signifie que la décision du
tribunal administratif de versailles et
définitive est bien valide ce qui vient
de se dérouler est important car la
juridiction des yvelines avec constater
l'illégalité de l'arrêté qui
restreignait l'accès aux biens de
première nécessité
officiellement le gouvernement recule en
expliquant que le taux d'incidence a
largement baissé je me dis que le
ministère de la santé cherche plutôt à
faire bonne figure
un goût de victoire qui pourrait donner
des idées à travers la france à nombre
de centres commerciaux concernés par
cette mesure et qui ont vu leur chiffre
d'affaires plonger de 30 % selon le
medef depuis l'entrée en vigueur du pass
c'est un fait il fait fuir les
consommateurs les centres en question
risquent donc de tous refusés
l'obligation du pass sanitaire au vu de
la réaction du ministère de la santé
c'est le conseil d'état qui dit no pasa
ni terre dans les centres commerciaux
mais l'assemblée nationale donne son feu
vert pour la prorogation de l'état
d'urgence sanitaire en outre-mer une
prolongation jusqu'au 15 novembre qui
doit encore être validée par le sénat
l'objectif est de combattre l'europe ont
leurs bons de l'épidémie de covin sur
les territoires ultramarins le point sur
la situation avec maxime abolin
l'état d'urgence sanitaire prolongé en
outre-mer impose initialement jusqu'au
30 septembre il va se voir prorogé
jusqu'au 15 novembre
l'assemblée nationale a validé le texte
de loi ce mardi qui doit être examiné
par le sénat ce jeudi mais au vu de la
situation sanitaire de plusieurs
territoires ultramarins l'état d'urgence
sanitaire devrait être adopté sont
concernés la guadeloupe la martinique
saint barthélemy saint martin la guyane
la réunion la polynésie française et la
nouvelle calédonie malgré des signes
d'amélioration ces territoires
connaissent une situation plus dégradée
qu'en métropole l'incidence épidémique
est en diminution dans les territoires
ultramarins
même si elle reste encore évidemment
élevé quant à la pression sanitaire la
pression hospitalière elle reste encore
très importantes sébastien lecornu s'est
rendu en guadeloupe ainsi qu'en
martinique j'étais avec lui en
martinique cet été nous avons vu de nos
yeux ce que voulait dire pression
épidémique dans des territoires
ultramarins où la vaccination est bien
trop faible entre 25 et 30 % de la
population totale seulement il a reçu au
moins une dose avec un variant elle pas
aussi contagieux est aussi dangereux
face à cette pression hospitalière le
gouvernement se mobilise pour apporter
de l'aide tout le déploiement de près de
deux mille de nos soignants 2002 le
soignant en un mois qui ont quitté la
métropole par avion pour aller aider
leurs collègues dans les territoires
ultramarins
2005 effort absolument sans précédent à
l'heure à laquelle je vous parle il y en
a huit cents d'entre eux qui sont dans
les territoires ultramarins loin de leur
famille pour quelques semaines pour
aider à sauver des vies ça compte de la
même manière des évacuations sanitaires
madame la députée à travers les océans
nous n'avions jamais fait dans ces
proportions une centaine ont été faites
depuis le début de la quatrième vague et
ça continuera bhl territoire jusqu'à
présent épargnée par l'épidémie
la nouvelle calédonie a été rajouté à la
liste par un amendement du gouvernement
on cause plusieurs cas de kovy 19
détecter ces derniers jours et pour
éviter toute propagation un confinement
strict 2 15 jours a été décrété
et la solidarité entre les pays ne
faiblit pas pour contrer la pole et
mouvant et demi de qu'ovide en tunisie
grâce à l'initiative d'un médecin franco
tunisien la région agricole d'elmina au
sud de la capitale s'est vu offrir
quatre ambulances et du matériel médical
pour soulager les habitants durement
éprouvé par la crise du coc vide grâce à
l'aide de médecins et bénévoles
d'auxerre le convoi a pu enfin arrivé en
tunisie un reportage signé bassam chebbi
et eser nasri
au port de la boulette c'est une
livraison vécue comme un soulagement est
perçu comme l'aboutissement d'un projet
humanitaire entre la tunisie et la
france quatre ambulances chargé de
respirateurs de concentrateurs d'oxygène
et pas moins de 28 mille masques ffp2
quitte enfin les services de la douane
tunisienne après un voyage de plus de 24
heures depuis auxerre dans l'yonne elles
sont enfin là pour le plus grand bonheur
de silane fils du docteur djemaa médecin
franco tunisien et initiateur du projet
alors rassurés bien sûr ça fait des
heures on attend devant le port que que
la marchandise elle sort les ambulances
et tout le matériel là on est rassuré
tout est là y'a rien n'a été touché la
douane a été super gentils nous ont
laissé faire ce qu'on voulait on perd il
a beaucoup travaillé en france pour
sortir tout ce matériel donc là vraiment
on est super content tout est là et on
va rendre heureux le peuple tunisien
avant que tout ce matériel soit
distribué dans le gouvernorat de nabeul
le convoi humanitaire doit passer par le
ministère de la santé passage
obligatoire pour régler les dernières
formalités administratives
ce matin dont le village d'el hmida 1h30
de tunis quelques villageois se sont
réunis autour du maire et du président
de l'association faire du bien aux
autres partenaires de ce projet
humanitaire devant le dispensaire du
village la joie se lit sur les visages
c'est au son des sirènes et floqué du
drapeau tunisien que deux des quatre
ambulances font leur entrée sous les
applaudissements de l'assemblée un
convoi précieux qui va permettre de
soulager le personnel soignant de cette
région agricole qui compte pas moins de
trente mille habitants une véritable
bouffée d'oxygène pour béchir bourguiba
merde delmi da pour qui ces dons vont
permettre d'améliorer l'autonomie des
collectivités locales et en diminuer la
dépendance vis-à-vis des métropoles
c'est un geste généreux de la part d'air
des français ont vis-à-vis des tunisiens
et surtout vis-à-vis d'elle hmida
spécialement on a un besoin énorme vu
qu'on n'a pas un hôpital local
qui peut subvenir aux besoins des
citoyens ce qui nous a poussé à faire
des ronds et la relation avec nos amis
en france l'arrivée de ceux du ces dons
ont changé pas mal de choses à elpida
les gens étaient contents d'avoir tous
ces matériaux ce matériel là et ils sont
contents d'avoir les moyens de transport
pour aller voir et les médecins
d'accorder du voisinage en pleine crise
sanitaire et dans un contexte
d'instabilité politique des centaines de
bénévoles issus de la diaspora ont
multiplié les initiatives citoyennes des
projets qui ont permis de combler les
lacunes d'un gouvernement en crise très
critiqué pour sa gestion de l'épidémie
en pleine quatrième vague le pays a
enregistré pas moins de 100 à 150 décès
par jour duo co-lead sur le taux de
mortalité le plus élevé du continent
africain grâce à la solidarité
internationale ambulance matériel
médical ou encore vaccin acheminé au
moins permis de soulager les services
médicaux tunisien
un israël à présent une quatrième dose
envisageable pour faire face à la
pandémie de kobe 19 une dose représenté
sous forme de rappel et qui pourrait
même être adaptées aux différentes
souches ducobu 19 le responsable de la
gestion nébuleuse plaide même pour une
injection régulière chaque année le
calendrier de cette vaccination n'est
pas encore défini et pour en parler nous
sommes en direct depuis à tel aviv avec
paula slayer journaliste international
rt internationale c'est notre rubrique
vu de l'extérieur
bonsoir paula merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france tout d'abord pour
bien qu'on comprenne qu'elle est la
situation sanitaire actuellement en
israël
singh
il y as jusqu'à dix mille nouveaux cas
par jour à la coop 19 les chiffres
augmentent depuis juillet
1300 personnes sont en ce moment
hospitalisé la moitié d'entre eux
sont des cas graves
c'était l'un de 30 personnes sont mortes
à ce jour de la ville
70 pays dont il s'agit d'un pays tout
vient ça vient d'un million d'habitants
sur son dos je tue vaccin à majorité
faiza
la troisième campagne de vaccination et
torigni cela a commencé avec les
personnes de 60 ans pouvait recevoir une
troisième construction rappelle
ce rappel est disponible à toute la
population
on évoque également effectivement un
quatrième rappel vous mettrais bien de
nous le dire troisième vos encours on
évoque un quatrième une quatrième dose
comment réagissent les isréliens ce
qu'ils acceptent la situation après une
troisième dose une quatrième est ce que
c'est envisageable
l'injection de fret être déployé à la
finale dames à 2021 au début ce livre de
la majorité des israéliens semblent
soutenir cette campagne de vaccination
une personne sur cinq cependant être
contre la vaccination
cela n'a pas toujours été le cas mais au
fur et à mesure de plus en plus de
personnes ont mis en question
l'efficacité
la campagne de vaccination
est le coordinateur de la réaction face
à la nuée mieux sera elle
expliqué avec avec l'apparition de
nouveaux variants il y aura de nouvelles
vagues il faudra donc y avoir de
nouveaux vaccins
on parle donc d'une nouvelle entité qui
correspondra à des rappels tous les six
mois où chaque année la plupart des
israéliens acceptent de cette situation
beaucoup d'israéliens sont également
préoccupés par la hausse des cas c'est
un taux de contamination est très élevé
à l'échelle du sud d'israël donc la
plupart d'entre eux soutiennent je tends
pas les vaccinations mais certaines
personnes se demandent si la vaccination
fonctionne vraiment s'il ya encore tant
de contaminer effectivement votre pays a
toujours servi de laboratoire en quelque
sorte pour ce vaccin vous le dit très
bien aujourd'hui des doutes
en tout cas des voix qui doutent de
l'efficacité de ce vaccin est ce que la
polémique s'arrête là où il ya vraiment
de gros réfractaires comme ici en france
où notamment il ya des manifestations le
voit antipas sanitaire par exemple
est-ce que la contestation est forte
aussi dans l'état hébreu
[Applaudissements]
oui
j'avais pas la même chose en israël par
rapport à la france il n'y a pas de
manifestations de masse contre les bacs
nous n'avons pas de telles
démonstrations de colère
c'est sans doute également comme de
france une question politique en israël
nous avons un nouveau gouvernement un
nouveau premier ministre naftali bennett
qui s'est montré très critique du
programme du premier ministre précédent
pénale ou les témoins ou s'agissant ce
deuil le confinement afin d'endiguer la
commune c'est pour cela qu'à ce jour il
n'y a pas eu doux et des finances depuis
la passation de pouvoir les gens sont
très inquiets a été confiné en israël la
plupart sont opposés au confinement et à
ses effets sur les causes du crash
tests sériques personnes pourront entrer
dans les pis pour la première fois
depuis 18 mois deze plongé de pénétrer
en israël et ils devront avoir reçu aux
vaccins et devront pouvoir présenter des
certificats ou alors un certificat de
tests de moins de 24 heures puis à leur
arrivée dans le pays ils devront
effectuer des tests un petit corps
donc c'est un début de programme et
maquillés commencera le 19 14 et qui
pourrait évoluer ce sera la première
fois en 18 mois je vous étrangers bien
rentrer sur le territoire israélien
la majorité de la population ça reçu de
vaccin de pfizer mais cela ne serait
efficace pour les activités qu'à 100 km
pour ça c'est un tout plus bas que oui
chiffres disponibles il ya quelques mois
et sans heurts lui-même réfute
statistiques oui un d'israël il ya
effectivement qui va grandissant mais la
majorité du pays soutient encore la
vaccination qui courent eux est le moyen
de sortir
situation actuelle avec la cofidis 9
merci beaucoup pour la flyer merci
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur rt
france
alors que certains experts annoncent une
nouvelle vad coronavirus l automne et
scientifiques cherchent toujours un
traitement efficace contre le coc vide
en russie des chercheurs sont sur le
point d'enregistrer le premier
médicament qui pourrait combattre le
virus lemire 19 les précisions de veyrac
hoffmann à moscou
plusieurs types de vaccins contre le
coronavirus existe déjà dans le monde la
russie a elle seule 1 à élaborer 5 mai
les vaccins c'est de la prévention
contre la maladie et si on est déjà
malade les scientifiques russes ont
développé un médicament qui serait
efficace contre le coronavirus le remède
vient de passer la deuxième phase
d'essais cliniques et pourrait devenir
le premier médicament au monde pour le
traitement du co lead
c'est l'institut d'immunologie de l'
agence fédérale de biologie et de
médecine qui a développé 1019 les
résultats des études précliniques ont
été publiées en avril dernier dans la
prestigieuse revue internationale
allergy ce qui a poussé des sociétés
pharmaceutiques du japon de la corée du
sud à s'intéresser aux médicaments us
à l'aide de ce médicament nous bloquons
très efficacement la multiplication la
réplication de ce virus en particulier
les études que nous avons menées en
phase pré clinique in vitro ont démontré
que l'utilisation du médicament mire 19
/ près de 10000 la charge virale est
bloqué la réplication du virus
nous travaillons maintenant sur la mise
à l'échelle sur la création d'une
technologie industrielle et bien sûr
j'espère vraiment que nous mettrons tout
en oeuvre pour diffuser le médicament
est que le prix n'affectera en rien sa
disponibilité pour population pas de
piqûre pas de comprimer le médicament
mire 19 est administré sous forme
d'inhalation comme le virus son filtre
dans l'organisme surtout par des voies
respiratoires supérieures
l'inhalation est le moyen le plus
efficace et le plus rapide pour faire
parvenir le médicament dans la zone
touchée par la maladie
prochaine étape pour les développeurs de
mire 19 l'enregistrement du médicament
auprès du ministère russe de la santé et
comme les chercheurs russes prévoient
d'exporter la technologie il s'apprête
également à publier les résultats de la
deuxième phase d'essai clinique dans une
revue scientifique internationale
mais la preuve ultime de l'efficacité du
médicament arrivera un moment où la
russie muni 2019 fera face à une énième
vague de coronavirus
rester avec nous dans quelques instants
début aujourd'hui du procès historique
des attentats du 13 novembre 2015 le
seul survivant des attaques salle
abdeslam s'est présenté à la cour en
faisons déjà parler de lui nous
décrypterons avec notre reporter cette
première journée d'audience et puis
place notre rubrique qu'en pensent les
français justement sur ce thème
[Musique]
non
est-ce qu'à une période de stabilité en
haïti est ce que ça a été est ce que ça
existe et je la fais plus de cent ans
que l'on avait assisté à l'assassinât
d'un président de la république d'haïti
l'état de droit a été véritablement mise
à mal pour permettre l'assassinât sur un
mode de crapuleux on a vu en fait se
constituer des armées privées qui
aujourd'hui ont totalement perdu le
contrôle de leur trou et lorsque ces
gangsters sont recrutés par des hommes
politiques ça vous donne une situation
pratiquement de guerre civile nous
sommes ici au coeur d'un système
extrêmement un briquet d'intérêt à la
fois intérieure et extérieure de toute
façon
mafieux cela ne peut que contribuer à la
dé construction d'un état moderne et
démocratique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
si paris cette saison avec lionel messi
remporte la ligue des champions ou du
symbolisme en termes de technique ce
sera absolument parfait et ils veulent
une fanfare impossible pour la coupe du
monde 2022 qui est la priorité de
l'émirat pourquoi le qatar utilise le
sport le foot plus particulièrement
comme outil de soft power ici vous
regarde en termes d'argent le fou ce
qu'on dit c'est de l'argent tu sais
c'est que dalle en fait ces pilotes donc
si vous voulez aujourd'hui être affiché
à travers tous les continents avoir une
image et en plus un an de la coupe du
monde c'est rêver pour le qatar parce
qu'on va reparler d'eux et encore pour
des raisons d'ailleurs plutôt mélioratif
plutôt permis
il n'y a pas une façon plus une pauvre
de défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre le peuple
c'était une volonté collective vous le
savez comme moi que dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative on sort du pays il
est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave est ce que c'est
normal si on veut sauver la vie sur
terre il est probable qu'il faille
prendre un certain nombre de mesures un
peu autoritaire c'est intéressant on
comprend que vous soyez des sous les
libéraux l'uniforme c'est quand même des
hommes comment ces mecs-là arrive à
dormir la nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a
vécu quelque chose d'inusité gilet jaune
c'était des valeurs de droite c'était
des gens qui travaillent c'est les gens
qui avaient envie de transmettre quelque
chose à leurs enfants qui
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas l'oubli
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est en direct il y a quand
même la liberté je vous remercie de
m'avoir invité
[Musique]
si paris cette saison avec lionel messi
remporte la ligue des champions tout du
symbolisme en termes de technique ce
sera absolument parfait et ils veulent
une fanfare d'un possible pour la coupe
du monde 2022 qui est la priorité peu de
l'émirat pourquoi le qatar utilise le
sport le foot plus particulièrement
comme outil de soft power et si vous
regardez en termes d'argent le faut ce
qu'on dit c'est de l'argent si c'est que
dalle en fait ces pilotes donc si vous
voulez aujourd'hui être affiché à
travers tous les continents avoir une
image et en plus un an de la coupe du
monde s'est réveillé pour le qatar parce
qu'on va reparler d'eux et encore pour
des raisons d'ailleurs plutôt mélioratif
plus tôt m
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous tes
pieds coup politique n'a jamais été
obligé de dire la vérité d idée
courageuse des mots qui comptent la
haine en soi vient des lignes
aujourd'hui on a une gauche extrême aux
usa
[Musique]
tous les témoins de notre époque sont
dans la grande interview
[Musique]
louis saillant est un ex commandos
marine il nous emmène dans les coulisses
de la guerre contre le djihadisme au
sahel l'ennemi l'abord est parfaitement
légitime qu'on parle de jay liste on
parle de gens qui recrutent des enfants
on parle de gens qui sont d'une barbarie
extrême cerexhe est un terreau qui peut
favoriser
l'extension du terrorisme ne faut pas
imaginer qu'il suffit simplement d'avoir
un pays pauvre pour que l'islam s'étant
bien mac sont embrigadés ils ont été
séduits ils ont été manipulés et
d'autres qui agissent de manière
parfaitement consciente et lucide je
respecterai toujours
l'adversaire même si je méprise
totalement son idéologie comme c'est le
cas pour sega liste
[Musique]
nairobi
m
[Musique]
il est 21h merci de nous rejoindre pour
cette deuxième partie d'émission
notre nouveau on et vous qu'en pensent
les français dans quelques instants
consacré ce soir à l'ouverture du procès
historique des attentats du 13 novembre
2015 à paris notre reporter questions
techniques et elle est à la rencontre de
parents endeuillés par l'assassinât de
leurs deux filles devant la terrasse du
carillon si les neuf mois d'audience
devrait faire la lumière sur de
nombreuses zones d'ombré l'enjeu
politique est réel quelles sont les
mesures prises par le pays pour faire
face aux terroristes corde est il du
suivi des fichiers s le pays est-il
désormais en mesure de prévenir ces
attaques nous en débattrons sur ce
plateau
[Musique]
est la première audience de ce procès
des attaques du 13 novembre s'est
ouverte donc un ennemi journée à la cour
d'assises spéciale de paris où un
important dispositif de sécurité a été
mis en place des centaines de crs de
gendarmes mobiles vont se relayer jour
et nuit lors de ce procès fleuve pour
lequel trois mille personnes seront
attendues certains jours
1765 parties civiles 330 avocat 20
accusés des chiffres impressionnants
pour un procès inédit guillemin rossi se
trouve sur place bonsoir guillemin que
retenir de cette première journée
d'audience
bien stéphanie comme vous l'avez dit ce
procès s'est ouvert un peu après 13
heures une première journée d'audience
qui a été consacrée à l'appel des
différents protagonistes dans ce dossier
alors premiers dans l'ordre alphabétique
salah abdeslam a été le premier des
accusés à prendre la parole est le seul
survivant du commando des attentats du
13 novembre n'a pas manqué de se faire
remarquer tee-shirt noir cheveux mi
longs barbe noire sous un masque noir le
franco marocain de 31 ans a paraphrasé
la chahada lé la profession de foi
musulmane musulmane je le cite il n'y a
pas de divinité à part à la et mohamed
est son messager il a ensuite refusé de
décliner l'identité de ses parents quant
à son métier je le cite là encore j'ai
délaissé toute profession pour devenir
un combattant de l'état islamique alors
pas de quoi impressionner le président
de la cour d'assises jean louis périès
65 ans et spécialisée de la criminalité
organisée mais les mots de salah
abdeslam ont bien fait réagir une partie
de la salle écouté
sa première réaction pour moi a donné le
la donc je vous cache pas que je me suis
un peu préparé je me suis préparé à la
fois sous le silence mais je me suis
préparé aussi aux réactions qu'il peut y
avoir parce que je pense que rien de sûr
réactions pour pas resté neuf mois man
cadre d'un procès et ne pas réagir à la
fois témoignage d'arrogance pour nom
des propos hallucinants
déclaré qu on a ni père ni mère à leur
père je veux bien mais mr ça me semble
un peu osé donc il est le fils de allah
c'est ce qu'il voulait dire
l'envoyé le fils de mal à ça dit tout et
ça ne laisse augurer d'aucune
d'aucune mon avis coopération future
dans le déroulement du procès
l'accusé ont simplement décliné leur
identité comme cela leur a été demandé
l'appel des parties civiles à occuper le
reste de la journée une journée est
également marquée par un malaise celui
d'un des accusés à cette occasion salah
abdeslam s'est une nouvelle fois exprimé
je le cite à nouveau cela fait plus de
six ans je suis traité comme un chien
mais je ne dis rien car après la mort on
sera ressuscité et vous devrez rendre
des comptes alors à sept secondes
provocation le président répond nous ne
sommes pas dans un tribunal
ecclésiastique nous sommes dans un
tribunal démocratique alors un premier
jour qui augure de l'épreuve que ce
procès représentera pour une partie des
victimes d'écoutés
depuis six ans on leur explique un petit
peu comment va se tenir le procès mais
c'est vrai que c'est un procès un peu
hors normes donc il va falloir surtout
la difficulté c'est de tenir les 9 mois
parce que c'est très long
donc très éprouvant parce qu'un procès
c'est très éprouvant pour les parties
civiles donc c'est surtout voilà cette
difficulté et puis on a un planning mais
le planning va évoluer au fur et à
mesure donc là aussi je leur ai dit
attendez il faut il faut faire attention
parce que certains ont déjà prévu de
venir tel et tel jour mais je leur dis
bon ben voilà il faut faut être assez à
l'écouté de ce qui va se passer parce
que les choses peuvent évoluer
alors vous l'avez entendu ce procès il
va durer neuf mois c'est la plus grande
audience criminelle jamais organisé en
france un procès hors norme historique
le procès du siècle selon sortes
certains un procès à la hauteur des
crimes commis les attentats du 13
novembre ont fait 130 morts et plus de
400 blessés l'attaqué la plus meurtrière
jamais commise sur le territoire
national depuis la seconde guerre
mondiale merci gaymard aussi merci
d'avoir été en direct pour vos
précisions
et alors que certains proches certains
proches de victimes sa patiente et
d'enfin pouvoir participer à ce procès
d'autres au contraire n'en attendent
rien du tout c'est le cas de sylvie et
éric pétards lors deux filles anna et
marion ont été assassinés par les
terroristes devant la terrasse du
carillon le 13 novembre 2015 dans qu'en
pensent les français ce soir quelle
technique est allé à leur rencontre
depuis ils pratiquent leur foi
catholique avec assiduité et leur parle
à travers la prière reportages sur des
images de renault parquet
nous sommes à blois aujourd'hui avec
sylvie eric pétards ou sommes-nous
sylvie c'est la basilique sainte trinité
à blois et on aime bien y aller parce
que quand on vient à blois pour
différentes choses on viens toujours ici
pour se recueillir
est-ce que vous pouvez nous nous parler
de vos filles qu'elles quel genre de
fille c'était comment qu'est ce qu'elle
aimait et bien les filles étaient
splendides normal c'était nos filles
c'est vrai qu'elle sent qu'elles sont
très belles et puis bale était très
avenante très ouverte à tous et elle
fonce et dans tout ce qu'elle
voulait entreprendre méfie
malheureusement ça ces états mais
sont toujours là mon esprit puis c était
tellement les mines est ce que que
sais je
[Musique]
voyez la dernière fois que j'ai vu ma
grande fille elle est menée m'embrasser
dans le groupe d à mon petit papa chéri
je t'aime voilà ça trois semaines après
c'était fini en fait la prière nous
permet de rejoindre les filles même si
elles sont tout le temps avec nous par
la prière elle elle participer elles
sont là tous les matins on se lève c'est
on embrasse nos fissures sur des photos
oui ça veut dire quoi ça
je souhaite à personne que ça arrive
mais moi personnellement j'ai du mal à
supporter et je le fais parce que c'est
mes filles et puis voilà j'ai envie j'ai
envie de les embrasser même s'il
s'absente
je ne participe plus à rien donc ce soit
même en idées ou en réaction beau
on arrive à vivre déjà tous les deux va
se lever le matin donc bon c'est pour
nous c'est déjà pas mal
[Musique]
bon
évidemment ce qui choquait toute
personne qui a eu à subir d'une manière
ou d'une autre ce drame c'est le fait de
d'entrer dans une sorte d' autre
dimension le terrorisme la violence pure
qu'elle est vous en avez pensé quoi ça
aurait jamais dû se produire quoi il il
faut réagir quoi parce que bon il ya
quand même charlie hebdo il ya des
prêtres il ya des gens annie se hisser
plein d'innocents et je ne vois pas
pourquoi que ça continue quoi il
faudrait peut-être quand même réagir
quoi parce que à chaque attentat on
prend des mesures patati patata là puis
finalement ça recommence tout le temps
quoi et d'ailleurs vous avez décidé de
ne pas assister au procès lorsque c'est
parce que voulez vous prémunir de toute
cette vague de l'énoncé de cette
violence ou est ce que c'est parce que
vous n'y croyez pas tout simplement mais
les deux se prémunir parce que je pense
que ça ne nous apportera rien à nous
deux encore un tout ce tout cet étalage
de deux faits puis et puis non croit pas
on croit pas aux réponses aux
explications qu'on peut pourrait
éventuellement avoir moi mon procès et
que ces gens devraient déjà plus exister
ça c'est sûr et puis en fait c'est pas
mon affaire le procès de ces gens là
c'est celle affaires de l'état elle
cherche des coupables pour se faire
pardonner mais bon moi
y'a rien qui passe je ne peux pas
l'accepter jeu donc le procès pour moi
c'est ça ramènera pas méfie d'une part
et puis en plus bas qu'est ce que vous
voulez
qu'est-ce que vous voulez que je dise
que je fasse
rien à dire rien à faire on peut même
pas se défendre
alors je vais pas faire la révolution
tout seul hein c'est pas possible les
pouvoirs publics de l'époque qui nous
ont su à l'école militaire non c'est
déjà incapable de diriger la france
c'était ça c'est sûr d'une part et en
plus ils se comportaient comme des
véritables le patin et aucune autorité
rien du tout oui monsieur oui monsieur
oui monsieur bré me dire ce que vous
voulez non non non
je ne peux pas accepter c'est décidé
dialogue comme ça
quand il ya des temps de mort et et
d'innocents surtout tombée sur le pavé
on se comporte en homme de
en homme de poigne un pan pour la bêta
et voilà forcément sont beaucoup de
détresse sachez que les époux pétards en
écrit un livre sur leur souffrance
l'espérance qui nous fait vivre
témoignages très émouvants publié aux
éditions artège et un couple qui on l'a
entendu ne participera donc pas au
procès neuf mois d'audience dont l'enjeu
politique est réel l'ancien président de
la république art d'ailleurs françois
hollande sera lui même auditionné alors
question au tout le monde se pose encore
et toujours aujourd'hui y at-il eu des
failles qu'elles sont depuis les mesures
prises par le pays pour faire face au
terrorisme
la france est-elle désormais en mesure
de prévenir ce genre d'attaqués on en
débat sur ce plateau place à notre face
à face
[Musique]
et avec nous pour en parler anthony
gratacos secrétaire général de la gauche
républicaine et socialistes bonsoir
anthony gratacos merci d'être avec nous
avec nous également direct avec 112 et
vice-président à l'ère du département
des sols merci d'être avec nous même un
petit peu plus loin mais en tout cas sur
ce plateau par le débat pour commencer
anthony bras tacos une attaque aux
pardons une réaction au commentaire de
cet homme évidemment meurtrissent papa
qu'on vient de voir les pouvoirs publics
de l'époque se sont comportés comme des
lopettes c'est dur mais est ce qu'il y
avait du vrai dans cette critique selon
vous tout d'abord je voudrais commencer
par saluer et rendre hommage aux
services de l'état aux enquêteurs qui
ont permis la tenue digne de ce procès
qui s'ouvre aujourd'hui
ce procès c'est d'abord un procès pour
les victimes mais c'est aussi un procès
pour la nation toute entière et pour
l'histoire alors évidemment je comprends
l'émotion de ce père que je viens
d'entendre mais je crois que l'état
à
jouer son rôle dans la prise en charge
des victimes dans l'accompagnement des
victimes et des familles parce que ce
n'était pas leur enfant qui était visé
en particulier c'était la société toute
entière qui a été visé à travers ces
attentats c'était notre mode de vie nos
façons de penser et donc c'est le rôle
de l'état de répondre à ses besoins à
cet accompagnement qui est nécessaire
qui va durer longtemps pour les victimes
et leurs familles là vous êtes dans
l'accompagnement des victimes et
effectivement c'est un point important
également viendra après justement sur
comment l'état à gérer les failles
éventuellement parce qu'il va en est
évidemment question tout au long de ce
procès mais restons effectivement dans
cet accompagnement des victimes
françois hollande justement l'avait
sacralisé cet accompagnement sous la
forme d'un secrétariat d'état qui était
rattaché aux services du premier
ministre
rattaché donc
au premier ministre de l'époque
portefeuille détenue par juliette mais
adel on regrette alex en 12 et la
disparition de ce secrétariat d'état
il coûtait effectivement c'était c'était
une novation il a été poursuivi soit une
forme interministériel je pense qu'il
faut dépasser la forme pour après que
l'état fait un effort substantiel pour
accompagner des victimes
individuellement et aussi peut-être
collectivement parce qu'il ya tout un
effort qui est fait un lieu de mémoire
étant en prévision justement pour aussi
que la nation puisse
passer
ce moment important se souvenir essayer
de davantage le comprendre alors bien
sûr et je m'associe à l'hommage qui a
été rendu
par mon collègue je pense qu'il faut
avoir une pensée à ce moment à la fois
pour toute et victimes leurs familles et
toutes celles et ceux qui sont
intervenus ce soir là les forces de
secours les forces de sécurité à
l'intérieur on avait célébré il ya
quelques années et qu'on dénigre trop
facilement aujourd'hui sont
aujourd'hui
vous comprenez anthony gratacos aussi la
colère de certaines victimes on a vu ce
papa évidemment qu'il ne souhaite même
pas participer au procès une autre
colère celle des victimes qui ont
entendu aujourd'hui un accusé salade et
cela nous dire voilà je suis dans le
combat tout simplement est resté mutique
en revanche sur le reste cette colère
elle est compréhensible aujourd'hui
clairement bien sûr que je la comprends
la colère elle est humaine mais la
réponse à la barbarie à laquelle on a
été confrontée elle ne peut pas être la
colère elle ne peut être que la dignité
et ce procès c'est la réponse
républicaine à la barbarie à laquelle on
a été confronté alors certaines victimes
certaines familles des victimes ils
trouveront du réconfort et d'autres non
je crois que c'est le cas de cette
famille ils le trouveront dans autre
chose mais on est en france dans un état
de droit où c'est la justice qui doit
permettre que les victimes trouvent une
réponse dans ce qui est dans ce qui
s'est passé on risque d'avoir du mal à
obtenir des réponses des accusés mais au
moins l'histoire sera dit alors
aujourd'hui évidemment on va pas faire
le procès on serait bien en peine de le
faire et on ne se permettrait pas bien
évidemment mais il est question des
files et tous les deux des responsables
politiques qui représentez votre parti
il ya bientôt des élections
présidentielles on ne va pas se voiler
la face clairement c'est ces failles
pour vous elles ont été clairement
présente on aurait pu peut-être éviter
certaines choses on rappelle que la
plupart des accusés était connu par les
services de renseignement il y a des
progrès à faire évidemment sans faire le
procès aujourd'hui ce soir de ces
attentats elle explosé
alors écoutez je regrette mes propos
soient mal utilisées là où c'est le
procès de terroristes c'est le procès de
l'islam politique c'est pas le procès de
la france en les principaux responsables
de ces actes terroristes
ils sont sur le banc des accusés c'est
pas pays c'est pas le gouvernement voilà
ceux ci
ceci étant dit c'est vrai que notre pays
à mon avis n'a pas bien appréhendé à
l'époque ces faits nouveaux autour de
tueries de masse et à peut-être
sous-évalué de risques de départs
de jeunes français sur zone à peut-être
sous-évalué c'est proto est acquis
secret a peut-être pas à créer les
services de renseignements qu'on a pu
dont le développement a suivi puisqu'on
a comblé ses lacunes et il est vrai que
la commission d' enquête
menée par le député fenech à l'époque à
relever aussi un son de problème sur
le renseignement sur la coopération
entre les pays notamment
entre la belgique et la grèce a relevé
aussi des sujets d'intervention des
forces de sécurité ces différents
problèmes je pense
aux était plutôt réglé
pour autant on a d'autres problèmes qui
arrivent aujourd'hui face à une mutation
de ce terrorisme avec ce n'était pas les
appelle le terrorisme d'atmosphère
servait des situations beaucoup plus
individuelle des petits groupes beaucoup
plus difficile à détecter et là je pense
qu'on n'est pas à nouveau aujourd'hui
pour lutter efficacement contre ce
nouveau phénomène on va en reparler en
tout cas on parler de cet enjeu
politique puisque encore une fois il est
bien réel l'ancien président de la
république à l'époque françois hollande
a accepté de témoigner il sera
auditionné le 10 novembre prochain je
vous propose de l'écouter
pour répondre à toutes les questions qui
me seront posées à la fois sur ce
qu'était la situation internationale et
notamment ceux qui se produisait en
syrie et en irak
quelle est l action de la france et
pourquoi avait-elle lancé des opérations
contre des terroristes islamistes dans
cette région je répondrai à toutes les
questions sur ce qu'on est et mes
décisions
anthony gratacos il a sa place
clairement le l'ancien président de la
république à cette audience est
important qu'ils s'expriment et qu'il
exprime sa version également oui je
crois qu'il est tout à fait légitime il
était en responsabilité dont il a été un
acteur important de
2,2 de ce moment et des attentats ce
n'est pas que qu'à un moment c'est aussi
un contexte et donc je pense que
françois hollande va aussi expliquer le
contexte dans lequel ça s'est déroulé
clairement françois hollande a on l'a
entendu chez nos confrères de france
info aujourd'hui
exclu tout est rare de la part du du
gouvernement ça vous semble être la
réponse appropriée clairement alexandre
touzet
aujourd'hui de la part du président de
la république
ancien
encore une fois la responsabilité
lehmann elle appartient aux terroristes
c'est pas le gouvernement français qui a
fait ces tueries de masse parce que je
crois que la défense des
terroristes n'hésitera pas jédir a
relevé une querelle interne pour essayer
de justifier ou d'excusé plus de plus ou
moins les actes ignobles conflit
accompli par ceux celles et ceux qui
sont sur le banc des accusés donc je
pense qu'il faut très clairement dire
que la responsabilité sont des
terroristes et le projet de l'islam
politique et après est ce que le
gouvernement était assez efficace ça
c'est une question qu'on peut se poser
une commission dentelle caroulle verse
dans le fait notamment sur comment on
organise des forces de sécurité
intérieure qui intervient en premier
quel et les pouvoirs de la force
sentinelle est ce que la berri était
peut-être la plus capée intérêt il ya un
ensemble de questions qui ont été posées
ces questions là je pense que
globalement
la france amélioré et renforcé son
enseignement elle a renforcé la
coopération avec des pays étrangers elle
a admis guide et que globalement on l'a
vu à nice très récemment en présence
d'un attentat ou c'est la police
municipale qui était la première sur
place qui est intervenu donc il ya toute
une série de réformes de la doctrine
de techniques d'intervention du
renseignement qui sont intervenus par
contre là où je m'inquiète c'est
effectivement comment on va s'adapter à
ce terrorisme entre guillemets un peu
plus l'adq on a pu voir la renaissance
et du terrorisme de masse comme on a eu
en septembre qu'on m'a eue là au
bataclan
ce terrorisme de masse je peux me disent
les s'agit de renseignements c'est qu'
il est plus difficile aujourd'hui à
mettre en oeuvre car s'il n'ya pas le
soutien des bases arrières qui
permettrait de à ce jour 1 pense qu'il
fallait prudent de le rencontrer à
nouveau
ce système de tueries de masse mais les
derniers faits on les pousse le
terrorisme plus individuel je dirais pas
le bourg-centre parce que pour moi c'est
une expression qui ne me convient pas et
là il faut vraiment très clairement à
adapter notre modèle qui a toute la
question de la bataille culturelle et
éducative c'est à dire est ce que l'on
considère qu' on laisse plein france est
une auberge espagnole où on leers on
laisse toutes les expressions se
développer ou est ce qu'on affirme des
valeurs républicaines la laïcité
l'éducation
la culture l'égalité entre les femmes et
les hommes au fond est-ce qu'on est une
société libérale anglo saxon où on fait
cohabiter des communautés et tout va
bien tant qu'à se tape pas dessus ou est
ce qu'on dit qu'on est une démocratie et
une république avec des valeurs a
affirmé donc il ya à la fois je pense
faire progresser les techniques
d'intervention le renseignement
j'allais dire aux contenus je pense à la
reconnaissance faciale par exemple et
puis aussi avoir un combat culturel
éducatif
républicain au sein de paix anthony
gratacos aujourd'hui clairement vous
vous sentez davantage en sécurité en
france qu' au lendemain de ces attaques
mais je penserai comme l'a dit alexander
je vais je pense que reçu 12 es se
trompent pas
d'abord il réfléchit pas à la bonne
échelle on est surtout dans le contexte
qu'on connaît depuis quelques semaines
on efface on était face à un terrorisme
international là où il y a eu une faille
bien sûr il ya eu des problèmes dans les
services français mais qui sont minimes
au regard des failles qu'il y a eu dans
les échanges entre les services
européens c'est l'accès géant belge et
français belges et français mais grec
c'est terroristes et les organisateurs
de ces attentats ont voyagé à travers
l'europe ils étaient fichés dans
certains pays suivie dans d'autres et ça
n'a pas été communiqué alors aujourd'hui
l'europe a réagi depuis 2015 et un
centre européen du renseignement qui a
été créé aux pays bas on est passé de l'
échange bilatéral entre services à un
échange qu'on appelle multi complet
c'est à dire que maintenant on échange
tout avec tout le monde sauf que ça
représente une masse de données et
d'informations colossal à traiter donc
il faut y mettre les moyens humains et
là dans le contexte qu'on connaît c'est
à dire la prise de l'afghanistan par les
talibans qui peut être une base arrière
pour des terroristes internationaux pour
se financer s'organiser et s'entraîner
on a plus que jamais besoin d'une
coopération et moyens internationaux
pour lutter contre après monsieur touzet
a raison sur un point c'est qu'on a un
sujet crucial moi j'appelle le
terrorisme discount c'est la personne
qui en france se radicalise via les
réseaux sociaux prend le premier couteau
qui lui passe sous la main et et commet
un attentat dans la rue en bas de chez
lui ça c'est du service de renseignement
fin et on n'a pas vraiment vous parler
d'efficacité des services français le
problème c'est qu'on connaît les échecs
des services mais on n'en connaît pas
par nature la réussite puisque c'est
frappé du secret défense et c'est aussi
bien d'ailleurs que les terrorismes
connaissent pas et points forts des
services secrets français chacun sait
que beaucoup de dates en tapant la
déclaration terminée l'intérieur sur
vous attentats ont été déjoués ne peut
pas vraiment on évaluer la réalité on
peut estimer effectivement ça arrive
assez souvent pour rebondir saura vous
promet vraiment j'insiste oui l'échelle
idoine aujourd'hui pour la lutte contre
le terrorisme international
c'est l'europe justement je voudrais
vous faire avec ou telle analyse de tivo
de demandes rihanna le président du
centre de réflexion sur la sécurité
intérieure
la menace terroriste est revenu au même
niveau de danger qu'en 2015 pour
plusieurs raisons d'abord on a sur notre
territoire beaucoup de gens qui sont
allés au jihad et qui sont revenus ces
gens là capacité de mener des actions
militaires coordonnées la deuxième
raison c'est qu'al-qaïda a cité la
france comme son ennemi principal dans
ces deux dernières vidéos
alexandre touzet d'accord avec ce
diagnostic de thibault de montbrial
tout à fait je crois qu'on est visée
parce que ont exprimé leurs fortes dalli
cité qui est assez propre à la france on
a la question bien sûr des caricatures
qui nous met aussi
en avant par rapport à d'autres pays et
puis je rajouterais toute la planète des
sortants de prison
c'est à dire que nous avons tout un
sujet du risque endogène les jeux
partage n'y a pas de différence entre
nous a été dit sur le risque
effectivement de nouvelles bases d'état
qui commencent à se consolider que ce
soit à 2 2 poches de proto et a que ça
sur scène
on avait une chance j'ai pas de sujets
là dessus mais on a un énorme risque en
interne avec des sortants de prison qui
ont été condamnés avant 2015 avant que
les peines soient fortes avec des
personnes extrêmement radicaliser avec
des personnes qui n'ont pas été
condamnés pour faits de terrorisme mais
qui se sont radicalisés en prison
et puis on a une partie de la jeunesse
qui aussi berric vers une forme de
radicalité religieuse qui n'est pas
forcément aujourd'hui une radicalité
violente qui s'expriment souvent à
travers
une expression religieuse extrêmement
forte
mais qui passent pas nécessairement à la
ddt on voit bien qu'on a tout un risque
endogène
aujourd'hui qu'on ne maîtrise pas
suffisamment
au regard de son ampleur et malgré ça je
partage l'investissement des services
l'investissement des policiers sur le
terrain l'investissement des services
sociaux des collectivités sur le terrain
parce qu'il s'agit aussi de
d'accompagner socialement certaines
familles de surveiller certains
individus et on est là face à une masse
critique extrêmement
importante anthony gratacos le mot de la
fin pour pour vous clairement ce que
emmanuel macron tant que chef de l'état
a pris la mesure de ce que vous nous
décrivez comme menaces et les problèmes
de fond du terrorisme concernant
emmanuel macron
je sors pas vous êtes socialiste et il
va défendre son bilan emmanuel macron à
un moment donné assez rapidement
les candidats de la présidentielle
puisque c'est l'inquiétude de nos
compatriotes c'est une question qui est
trans partisane où vous voyez bien que
avec monsieur touzet on est d'accord sur
la plupart des sujets il peut y avoir
des comment dire des nuances il peut y
avoir aussi un problème de cohérence par
rapport à ce qu'on défend et à ce qu'on
fait c'est à dire que des gouvernements
qui ont été au pouvoir n'ont pas mis les
moyens aussi dans ses services pour
pouvoir faire de la prévention contre le
terrorisme on a connu une politique
d'austérité très grande à partir de
l'élection de nicolas sarkozy à la tête
de l'état je suis pas sûr que ça n'est
pas lui un rôle dans l'appauvrissement
des services les manques de moyens en
personnel et la diminution même de ses
personnels dans ses services il faut
savoir ce qu'on veut
il faut admettre que emmanuel macron de
ce côté là pour ce qui concerne j'ai
plein de reproches à lui faire sur
beaucoup d'autres services de la
fonction publique mais en la matière
dans la foulée des politiques qui ont
été engagées après 2015 il les a pas
remis en cause il les a plutôt encouragé
merci à tous les deux ans tony agritech
de sources plateau alexandre choses et
merci à vous d'avoir accepté ce débat ce
soir et c'est la fin de cette émission
se retrouve demain pour un nouveau
rendez vous à 20h prochain point sur
l'actualité dans une trentaine de
minutes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bienvenue dans la grande interview
consacrée aujourd'hui aux victimes des
attentats du 13 novembre 2015 à paris
alors que le procès va s'échelonner
durant neuf longs mois ces terribles
actes terroristes ont fait 130 morts des
milliers de blessés de vies brisées de
familles détruites et aujourd'hui les
survivants et leurs proches sont aidés
dans leur difficile reconstruction par
les associations et par l'état bien
évidemment et nous allons parler de tout
cela avec jérôme moreau merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation
alors vous êtes vice président et porte
parole de la fédération france victime
il s'agit d'un réseau d'associations qui
aide les victimes de toute nature que ce
soit par exemple le terrorisme les
cambriolages les violences conjugales
les accidents et je voudrais savoir
comment vous avez abordé comme vous
abordez ce procès historique
alors effectivement procès historique
puisque c'est un procédé d'envergure qui
n'a jamais eu lieu en france il faut
déjà le préciser et nous l'avons aborder
très sereinement
avec rigueur c'est à dire que nous avons
participé notamment paris aide aux
victimes qui est l'association phare de
la fédération sur ce procès eh bien nous
allons participer à l'organisation tout
d'abord à les séances de travail avec
les juridictions et puis avec les
victimes bien entendu pour les
accompagner jusqu'au cheminement de ce
procès qui va s'ouvrir le
né le 8 septembre et pour leur permettre
d'aborder ce procès dans des conditions
les plus favorables possibles dans le
cadre quand même d'un procès qui va être
très dur pour elle alors justement il y
à de nombreuses de conditions qui ont
été mises en place pour que tout se
passe bien alors au niveau évidemment du
rendu de la justice mais également de
l'attention de l'aide apportée aux
victimes avec un accompagnement
psychologique par exemple vous pouvez
nous parler de toutes ces mesures qui
ont été mises en place alors tout
d'abord c'est une salle d'audiences
spécifiques il faut le préciser qui a
été construit spécifiquement pour le
procès 750 m² 600 personnes qui vont
pouvoir intégrer cette salle d'audience
dix autres salles
autour de cette salle d'audience pour
permettre au maximum de personnes de
pouvoir assister au procès alors
effectivement toutes les victimes ne
pourront pas rentrer dans la salle
d'audience mais on va faire un espèce de
tourner over si on peut dire comme ça au
moment leurs dépositions au moment de la
plaidoirie des avocats en tout cas tout
est organisé et normalisé pour elle
la deuxième chose c'est que nous avons
préparé les victimes bien évidemment
paris et de victimes a
organisé des visites sur les lieux ce
qui est extrêmement important puisqu'on
va pouvoir voir que dans cette ancienne
cour d'appel de paris eh bien on a une
salle très solennelle mais il faut les
mettre à l'aise les victimes et puis on
prépare les victimes à témoigner pour
celles qui le souhaitent on prépare les
victimes aussi à pouvoir écouter le
procès puisque pour la première fois le
procès sera équipée d'une web radio donc
on va peut-être en parlais tout à
l'heure mais en tout cas elles auront un
code spécifique elles pourront suivre
deux chez elle parce que vous l'avez 19
mois c'est très long et donc l'attend
pas pouvoir assister à toutes les
audiences tout le temps donc voilà et
puis effectivement un étayage
psychologique très important
tout d'abord dans le palais de justice
puisque paraît de victimes à 18
personnes 12e psychologue et puis toutes
les associations c'est à dire les 130
associations pour le terrain sont
mobilisés savent qu'à tout moment elles
peuvent accueillir une victime qui de
chez elle
s'effondrerait qui de chez elles
éprouveraient le besoin de revenir sur
ce qu'elle a subi ce qu'elle a traversé
et donc tout le réseau les 130
associations
métropolitaine et ultramarine sont
mobilisés bien évidemment autour de la
fédération et autour de paris et de
victimes pour accompagner au mieux ses
victimes c'est dire que vous avez
préparé la prise de parole et un
psychologue ou quelqu'un qui qui lui a
peut-être expliquer comment elle allait
se produire ce qu'elle allait peut-être
dire c'est ce genre de préparation alors
effectivement on leur a expliqué comment
allait se dérouler l'audience d'abord
parce que c'est d'abord eu encore une
fois une audience extrêmement longue
donc c'est pas banal le rôle des avocats
est essentiel aux siens puisque quand
elles vont déposer il va falloir
qu'elle sache ce qu'elles veulent dire
est ce qu'elles veulent exprimer et ça
aussi c'est une préparation en lien avec
les associations les avocats et les
victimes bien évidemment et puis après
effectivement ça va raviver très
certainement des souvenirs extrêmement
douloureux donc mais ça on va les
accompagner au jour le jour parce que on
sait faire je disais qu'il y avait mille
800 parties civiles mais certaines
victimes n'ont pas voulu se constituer
en fait comme si elle souhaitait tourner
la page est ce que c'est fréquent en
tout cas pour celles qui se sont
constitués parties civiles quel est le
rôle de ce procès alors je crois que les
victimes attendent trois choses pour
celles qui se sont constituées parties
civiles
tout d'abord
de pouvoir témoigner de pouvoir dire les
choses et c'est extrêmement important de
pouvoir le dire dans une enceinte qui
représente les institutions qu'ils
représentent la nation une exigence de
vérité bien évidemment alors est-ce que
le principal survivants auteurs parlera
salade et slam c'est tout l'enjeu aussi
et je crois que ce sera un des temps
fort du procès et puis une exigence de
justice et une condamnation exemplaire
il faut le rappeler quand même par cette
cour spécialement composée
des peines extrêmement lourdes et puis
certaines datant de rien et j'y mettrai
celles qui se sont constitués parties
civiles et celles qui ne se sont pas
constitués partie civile parce que
effectivement certaines ont tourné la
page certaines ne veulent plus en parler
en direct et nous ça va on a réussi à
remonter la pente on a réussi à faire
notre deuil
à nous d'écrire des blessures voilà donc
laissez nous tranquilles tout cela en
tout cas ne se juge pas ne se commande
pas et chaque victime va trouver en
elle-même les possibilités de faire
preuve de résilience à son rythme et
selon ce qu'elle souhaite et alors vous
france victime la fédération comment
at-elle agi juste après les attentats
parce qu'on a parlé de lettres que vous
avez apportée aux victimes qui vont se
présenter mais juste après alors
évidemment au moment de la crise nous
avons été diligentée mobilisés par le
ministère des affaires étrangères et le
ministère de l'intérieur nous étions
tout de suite dans les cellules de crise
au niveau ministériel le réseau a été
immédiatement mobilisé nous avons tout
de suite envoyé des notes aux
associations en disant attention toute
la france est susceptible d'avoir des
victimes d'infractions la première chose
qu'on a faite c'est accompagné
accueillir les victimes dont elle
voulait bien que là nous les
accompagnons bien évidemment par un
accompagnement psychologique tout
d'abord c'était la première chose
débriefer et puis nous avons donné au
fur et à mesure toutes les informations
en notre possession à toutes les
victimes au fur et à mesure de
l'instruction et puis nous les avons
accompagnés au procès je veux aussi
souligner que l'accompagnement
effectivement de la crise jusqu'au
procès à être une première étape le
procès constituera une seconde étape et
puis après parce qu'il y aura un après
procès eh bien il va falloir que les
victimes qui n'ont toujours pas tourné
la page
parce qu'elles attendent ce procès parce
qu'elle espère un certain nombre
d'éléments parce qu'elle espère à terme
de choses et bien là il va falloir que
les victimes entament ce long et
douloureux processus également de
reconstruction mais ça sera après le
procès et la va se nouer encore d'autres
choses donc nous les avons nous allons
les accompagner du début de la crise
jusqu'à leur reconstruction tant est que
ce soit possible pour certaines et
combien de personnes avez vous aidé 3050
sur uniquement c'est les attentats du 13
novembre
en tout à l'heure actuelle pour vous
donner une idée avec les attentats du 14
juillet de nice et puis les différents
attentats qui ont émaillé
malheureusement la france après nous
sommes à plus de 7000 victimes donc nous
avons une vraie expérience une vraie
expertise j'ai envie de dire bien malgré
nous et bien malheureusement sur ces
questions mais c'est aussi la force d'un
réseau de 130 associations et d'une
fédération alors comment vienne telle
verve ou est ce que vous attendez
qu'elle vous contacter ou est ce que
c'est vous qui allez au devant d'elle et
après vous les répertorier comment ça se
passe alors nous avons eu tout de suite
les listes des victimes à la suite des
attentats du 13 novembre toutes les
victimes blessées bien évidemment toutes
les cordes des familles endeuillées bien
évidemment et puis nous avons accueilli
également toutes les victimes
qui étaient plus ou moins concernés au
sens juridique
strict par part par les attentats mais
qui ont éprouvé le besoin d'avoir des
accompagnements parce qu'il connaissait
quelqu'un de très proche parce qu' il
n'était pas très loin parce qu'ils
avaient assisté
aux scènes et donc nous avons considéré
que la notion de victime était
extrêmement élargie et que toute
personne qui avait besoin d'un
accompagnement devait être accompagné
c'est ça qui fait aussi je crois notre
différence notre distinction avec un
certain nombre d'institutions c'est que
nous n'avons justement pas sélectionner
toutes les victimes dont nous avions les
coordonnées bien évidemment nous les
avons accompagnés et nous les avons
contactés et nous restons en lien avec
elle et puis un certain nombre de
personnes sont venues et donc toutes ces
personnes nous les avons bien évidemment
accompagné et nous poursuivons
l'accompagnement tenté qu'elles sont
nées en ont besoin ce qui a énormément
de choses qui reviennent ce comme vous
dites il ya une sorte de définition
élargie à la victime ça peut être
journaux un témoin oui bien sûr pour
vous ça peut être un témoin ou quelqu'un
qui a été extrêmement gravement